you're talking to an old lady today I'm  sending Jacob into CVS to buy some  condoms some very specific condoms  but that sounds large I don't know if  that's gonna work for me okay ask her if  she thinks it's possible to take the  chapstick out and just use that tube I  mean do you think it's possible if I  just like if I get a regular chapstick  to just take the chapstick out and use  the two like do you think that'll work  or or like do you guys have any extra  slips like you know the rolls of pennies  when you put pennies in a roll like the  size of a small sandwich bag anything  like that  no hey I'm Josh Wolf and I'm Jacob wolf  and this is family tussle the father-son  competition show where the loser has to  do an embarrassing punishment